The explosive third season finale of You has
everything, from roast dinners to die for,
to extreme cage therapy, and a big twist setting
up Season 4.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!
I'm Jan and in this video I'm breaking down
all the things you might have missed in the
ending of You Season 3, the clues that predicted
the shocking conclusion, and what the future
holds for Joe.
We'll be talking spoilers, so take care if
you're not all caught up.
The fact that Joe would end up permanently
severing his and his son's ties with Love
in the finale was foreshadowed all the way
back in the opening scene of the season where
he cut the umbilical cord between Love and
baby Henry.
And, just an episode later, it was also hinted
at by the couple's therapist who had no idea
of the serial killers she had for clients.
Neither one of you is gonna kill your spouse.
You're many things, but you are not murderers.
The problems in Joe and Love's marriage come
to a head in the final episode when she serves
him roast chicken, which she figured out was
his favourite meal on their very first night
out together.
Perfect bite?
Perfect.
That was also the night Joe found out about
Love's dead husband and when they both discovered
how alike they were.
Fast-forward to now where it's the dying days
of their relationship, and roast chicken and
dead husband discussion are back on the menu,
with Love admitting to killing her first spouse
by accident when she tried to temporarily
paralyse him with aconite to stop him from
leaving her.
And now it's Joe's turn as he unwittingly
grabs a poison-laced carving knife that Love
set to trap him!
This time, I'm letting it absorb through the
skin.
None of this would be happening if you hadn't
grabbed a weapon.
In their twisted obsession, Love and Joe are
almost mirror images of each other, so she
realised he'd go for the knife.
Love knows me better than anyone ever has.
I'm starting to understand why that's so terrifying.
By the way, notice how Love used a glove to
handle the carving knife before this so she
wouldn't get the poison on her own hand.
Love's choice of aconite, which is commonly
known as wolfsbane, has an extra level of
meaning in this show because the word "wolf"
used to be part of her and Joe's special love
language.
I love you.
Is there another word we can use?
I wolf you.
I wolf you too.
And in Season 3, when Joe and Love are struggling
to enjoy sex together, he bemoans the fact
they don't say "I wolf you" any more.
We've been domesticated.
I wolf you.
Wolf?
Or dog-on-a-leash?
There were also a few possible hints in Season
2 towards Love's eventual use of wolfsbane
on Joe when she playfully attacked him with
a toy wolf, a gesture that also signalled
her penchant for slashing her victims' throats;
and, there was also the real wolf the Quinns
brought to the wellness weekend which snarled
aggressively at Joe.
Interestingly, after Marienne's advice to
listen to the 'tiny voice' in her own head,
Love realises how many things are wrong in
her relationship.
I mean, you gaslit me so hard.
I'm not the problem.
My husband is the problem.
And she decides to cut her losses and goes
to kill Joe with the same cut-throat MO she
used on most of her previous victims.
But Joe's already turned the tables on his
mirror-image wife;
she just doesn't realise she's been hoisted
by her own petard until he stabs her in the
leg with a syringe full of her own deadly
wolfsbane.
Our love language is violence.
And in a little visual gag, the jar of poison
Joe pulled the wolfsbane from was labelled
'Dye Sample'.
Oh, and despite Joe's unfavourable views of
the Madre Linda dads when he first meets them..
the haze of narcissistic delusion that just
the right biohack, you'll live forever.
..it's actually biohacking that saves his
life in the end.
By the way, notice that Joe didn't eat anything
before he saw Love eat because he was already
worried about being poisoned, a call-back
to when Love brought him muffins after trapping
him in his cage in Season 2.
Is this what you're afraid of?
No poison, Joe!
Given their one-upmanship with poisonous wolfsbane,
Love and Joe have certainly brought very literal
meaning to the term 'toxic relationship'.
Joe's recipe for a successful getaway involves
cooking up a salacious story to keep everyone's
minds occupied with juicy details, the aim
being to stop them asking awkward questions
about how true it is.
And he certainly knows his audience because
the people of Madre Linda love to gossip and
are more interested in manufactured reality
than reality itself.
For the public, the brand is conventional
monogamy.
So, Joe sprinkles just enough believable information
into the tale he concocts.
Cue him preparing a Chicken Pot Pie, using
against Love the fact that she's a "trained
pastry chef" and well-known as the town's
baker.
And it's all somewhat ironic that part of
Joe ends up in Love's chicken pie given chicken
was his perfect bite in their early loved-up
days and their wedding vows even included
pastry:
You said you would always share a bite of
your pastry with me, no matter what.
Intriguingly, Joe's final plan was foreshadowed
in the opening episode:
This isn't some German fairytale where a witch
keeps me locked up till it's time to eat me.
That's a shout-out to Hansel and Gretel where
the witch who plans to eat the children is
outwitted by them and ends up dying in her
own fiery oven.
On top of that, the way Joe turns Love into
a legendary figure akin to the baker who made
murder victims into meat pies in Sweeney Todd..
the Mrs Lovett of Madre Linda
..is especially apt because in the musical
version of that story, Todd burns the baker
Mrs Lovett to death after shoving her into
an oven, while in the original story he kills
her with poison.
And let's not forget the little box of gruesome
mementos that Joe leaves at Love's side.
As well as Gil's driver's license, there's
a bunch of teeth, probably Natalie's.
We know Joe removed them to avoid dental records,
as he did with Benji, and remember he wouldn't
tell Love what he'd done with them.
I just don't wanna find them in a hidey-hole
in my house.
You won't.
It's safer if you don't know.
Given that earlier in the same episode, Love
refused to tell Joe what she'd done with Candace
and Delilah's bodies...
It's safer if you don't know
..I imagine Joe kept the teeth in case Love
tried pinning those Season 2 deaths on him.
After all, he admits to hanging on to another
of Natalie's possessions for similar reasons
and suggests using that to frame Matthew for
her murder.
With all the evidence in place to frame his
dead wife, Joe sets the house on fire to ensure
the crime scene is damaged enough to make
the faked murder-suicide more plausible.
He leaves the burning building to go in search
of Marienne, exactly as was foreshadowed several
episodes earlier.
For you, Marienne, I will walk through fire.
There were also some other early hints that
telegraphed how Love would end up getting
the blame for torching the house.
All you ever showed me was to get the prince,
build a castle, and then burn it all to the
f!$*%@# ground.
Then there was Love's mother Dottie who set
light to her own vineyard during a bitter
divorce, which would doubtless lead the town
gossips to say, "Like mother, like daughter".
And at the library gala when Joe was panicking
about Love and Marienne meeting up, his inner
monologue predicted the events of the final
episode.
I should orchestrate a disaster in the kitchen
truck, turn up the oven, scorch the quail.
It's like I'm watching my own execution.
Perhaps influenced by Love's dying words...
We're perfect for each other.
But bad..
for Henry.
..Joe realises he might not be a good father
and if he stays he'll be locked up as her
accomplice, setting his son off on the same
damaging path as himself.
So, he tearfully leaves his baby with Dante
and Lansing.
And Henry's in safe, caring hands instead
of Dottie's unstable, sozzled ones or the
lonely, potentially bullying hands of a group
home.
So, hopefully for Henry, Joe's broken the
harmful cycle set in motion by his own parents.
At the start of the finale, Love told Kiki
& co they were a "bunch of scandal-hungry
crows"..
No amount of feasting on other people's sorrows
is gonna make your lives less hollow.
But by the end of the episode, those same
people are having a really good go at proving
Love wrong as they dine out on her misery,
building businesses profiting off her death.
From the jokey pseudo-feminist rebrand of
her bakery targeted more at selling Insta-worthy
t-shirts than good quality food like Love's;
Yelp suggests the scones are just okay.
to the at-home test for poison inspired by
her use of toxic wolfsbane;
to a self-help bestseller about kidnapping
and caging.
Caged: A Radical Couple's Therapy Technique.
As for Marienne, she takes Love's advice to
get away from Joe, leaving no phone number
or address behind.
Due to her ex-husband, she already knew the
dangers of toxic relationships.
I promised myself, my next relationship would
be aboveboard and honest.
And, though she'd pushed it aside, she'd had
a bad feeling in her gut about Joe.
Something in me knew that it was too good
to be true.
In fact, her words in that moment echo Beck's
view of Joe in the Season 1 finale:
And you knew, somewhere deep, it was too good
to be true.
Unlike Joe, who believes in fairy tales..
How do I make you see I could be your happily
ever after?
..Marienne doesn't believe in damsels in distress.
Instead, her favourite fairy tale is Jack
And The Beanstalk.
Jack was a little badass.
I wanted to be him.
Screw princesses.
So, given all that then, when Joe wonders:
Did you pity me when you read what happened?
Did it erase the fear she planted?
Do you still think about us?
I imagine Marienne's answer would be a big
fat "no"!
The season ends with Joe taking his creepy
stalking act on the international road..
I have to believe our paths are destined to
cross again.
Paris is his destination of choice as Marienne's
originally from there and she told him during
her custody battle that's where she'd run
to with her daughter if she thought her ex-husband
wouldn't find them.
And spend our days drawing outside Sacré-Coeur.
Though Marienne mentions the famous basilica
of Sacré-Coeur, he's actually here as it
has fantastic views of the Eiffel Tower, which
immediately signals to viewers where Joe is.
The name of the café is "Le chasseur solitaire",
which translates into English as "The Lone
Hunter", brilliantly fitting for Joe Goldberg
and his continued solo predator activities.
I think I'm meant to be a lone wolf.
It does feel kind of ironic that after Joe
lied about his ex, Candace, leaving him and
running off to Europe, that's what seemingly
has actually happened with Marienne.
This isn't the first time that Paris has popped
up on the show as a place to get away and
start fresh either.
Peach wanted Beck to move there with her and
live at her parents' flat.
Paris could be a new beginning for the both
of us.
And, after caging Delilah in season 2, Joe
suggested the French capital to Love as a
place to wipe the slate clean:
What if we leave together?
Start over.
You could finish cooking school in Paris.
By the way, those jingling bells on the café
door are meant to make us think of Beck, Joe's
first main infatuation in the series, which
in many ways indicates he's right back where
he started.
Yes, he's in a new city, a new country even,
but he's still the same old Joe.
The barista may call him "Nick", a sign that
he's taken on a new identity for this next
chapter, but Joe already has form for this.
In LA, he kidnapped Will Bettelheim and stole
his identity;
though he did eventually free him and they
kept in contact, so maybe Will helped him
out with a fake passport to get out of the
US.
And perhaps Joe picked the name Nick, subconsciously
thinking of Dr Nicky, the man he falsely framed
for the murder of Beck in New York.
Although Joe's delusional antics in You are
intriguing to watch, in real life to keep
our personal details away from creeps and
snoopers like him, we all need to improve
our online security.
And a crucial part of keeping your online
life private is using a VPN whenever you're
online.
If you're using public Wi-Fi, like in a coffee
shop, you're especially at risk from hackers
who can break into your connection and access
any personal data being transmitted.
Using a quality virtual private network on
your mobile devices like your phone and laptop
will make sure you're protected against these
threats, which is why at Flicks And The City
we recommend NordVPN.
A virtual private network creates a secure,
encrypted tunnel between your device and a
VPN server, stopping your internet service
provider or any other agencies from tracking
you online, reading your emails and private
messages, or seeing what websites you're visiting.
Nord has an incredibly intuitive interface
which lets you connect up to six devices at
the same time so can you use it on your computers
at home as well as phones, tablets and laptops
whenever you're out.
And, unlike free VPNs, Nord is incredibly
fast with over 5000 servers in over 60 countries
worldwide.
Nord is also great at helping you access any
content which may be restricted in your region.
You simply connect to a server in another
country and then browse the internet as if
you were there.
For a limited time, all our viewers can grab
a very special offer of a huge 73% off a 2-year
plan, plus 4 bonus months for free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/Flicks or go to the
link in the video description to get the offer.
Or use coupon code FLICKS when you check out.
So, what did you think of Season 3 of You
and how it ended?
And what's in store for Joe next?
Leave your thoughts and theories in the comments
below.
Coming up are more You videos with all the
easter eggs you missed in Season 3 and more
Season 4 theories.
You can tap here to watch those and if you
enjoyed this then a thumbs-up and a share
are hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!